w polityce yy zagranicznej
w ogóle w polityce yy potrzebne jest chłodna głowa
Jak yy słyszę wystąpienia yy posłów lidera yy pis-u
to Tam 80% yy przekazów anty
jest kierowane przeciwko unii europejskiej
nie nie
nie słyszymy tyle złego
putiniec o niemcach o o unii europejskiej
oczywiście Unia Europejska jest yy polem też
brutalnej rywalizacji yy o interesy narodowe
to jest naturalne
ale polska może dzisiaj odgrywać mocniejszą rolę
niż zapisu podczas yy
podczas yy rządu wpisu
polska była na marginesie polityki europejskiej
EE dzisiaj słyszymy zarzuty o tą potencjalną
federalizację ym europy
warto przypomnieć
że nie kto inny Jak yy
yy premier Jarosław yy Kaczyński
jego rząd negocjował ym traktat lisboński
który osłabił
wagę głosu ym pojedynczego państwa mniejszego
takiego Jak Jak polska wobec yy tych ym hegemonów
niemiec yy francji
yy a podpisał do świętej pamięci yy prezydent lek
Kaczyński także pamiętajmy o tym
jeśli ktoś yy w tej kategorii myślenia
najbardziej zaszkodził suwerenności yy polski
to właśnie yy rząd pisu
który wyraził na to zgodę